One of the benefits of LDN, LDN is low dose,
Deltrexone, Deltrexone was initially a drug that was issued
for the help of getting off of heroin, I think,
and some other, you know, street drugs.
But it was approved at 50 milligrams.
So low dose, Deltrexone is starting at 1.5 milligrams,
and going to 3 milligrams, going to 4.5,
maximum milligrams, that's considered low dose, Deltrexone.
It was fun to be a immune system regulator, a T-reg
stimulator, is what a technical terminology is.
So remember you have these two sides of your immune system,
this inflammatory side and this anti-inflammatory side.
And they're not good or bad, they're both good with imbalance.
And at time of an immune up regulation to kill pathogens,
you have this TH1 hyperfunction, your TH2 system suppress,
and you have this more inflammatory but deadly immune response
to kill something.
And people that have autoimmune disease
can have this bounce back and forth and can be stuck
at a TH1 dominance and can cause damage to cells
that you have antibodies against, like the Hashimoto's or MS,
where you have antibodies against violent sheet cells,
and you have stuck at a TH1 dominance,
you're continually progressively damaged,
that what you have antibodies against.
And if it's self-tissue, that's not good.
LDN, well, you have what's called a T-reg system in your body.
That means it regulates this TH1, TH2 response
and brings it back into balance.
And there's different nutrients that are T-reg nutrients.
Vitamin D has been found to be here.
Take vitamin D if you've got a cold, because it's a great immune stimulator.
Well, that's not actually true.
Vitamin D is a T-reg stimulator.
So it helps balance an out-of-balance immune response.
Some people get sick all the time because they're stuck at a TH2 dominance.
So taking T-reg stimulators can help bring that back in the balance
so that your TH1, TH2 system will work more balanced
and correctly, medicinal mushrooms.
They're a great immune stimulators.
Not really. They're immune regulators.
They're T-reg stimulators.
So if you're out-of-balance where you don't have a good immune response,
they will help boost that immune response.
If you're out-of-balance, you have too much immune response,
aka an autoimmune disorder, they'll help bring that down.
LDN does that as well.
So low-dose deltrexode is a drug that can be a T-reg stimulator.
Well, why don't we use that more often for cancer?
Because it is a drug and it has side effects.
To me, it shines more
with people with serious autoimmune disease than it does with people with cancer.
Hope that helps.